I think there's going to become I mean
you can't put the kinds of people out on
the street and we're talking
30 percent by 2030. unemployment double
that of the Great Depression and it's
never coming back
you can't put those kinds of people out
on the street and expect things to go
well so they better have a good handle
on you and a way to keep you as Naval
Harare says um uh medicated and online
um so I think that there is going to be
a couple of things could happen if we're
really fortunate uh one there could be a
Great Awakening kind of like the Jesus
movement of the 70s which took the
hippie movement which was going downhill
quickly into drugs and everything else
and turned it into an uplifting kind of
movement the Jesus hippies there's a
chance that life
be has become so meaningless in a way
that it did kind of in the 1960s that we
will find meaning again
how worried are you that even if the
machines aren't taken over and and
literally Exterminating us that just
what they could do in terms of what guys
like you and I do for a living just try
to translate the insanity into something
sensible for people that that will be so
cordoned off maybe we're there already
that you will rarely ever meet anyone on
this planet who thinks the same things
that you do or even roughly the same
things meaning that we will have all
been so atomized and manipulated through
algorithms and everything else
it will be impossible to agree on
anything
so I don't fear the machine first I
don't think the first step is it takes
over I think that's a a longer process
and I'm not sure how that happens if
that happens
um I do know that it becomes more and
more powerful and
with that power
come people
and people who are in charge of that
power
um I I think the dystopian world of even
possibly 2030 is that you don't go
anywhere Dave you and I talking to each
other each other if I am on some list
which I can guarantee you I'm on if I'm
on some list and you talk to me your
score goes down and so we can't talk to
each other unless we don't you know
unless we don't want to uh
you know fly again there's this great uh
article I just it's in the book I'm
trying to remember where I got it from I
think it's from UNESCO
um and it was written in 19 I mean sorry
in 2019 and it talks about two people
and this husband and wife and and this
is their idea of a Utopia of Tomorrow by
2030. that he takes the rapid transit he
takes the train I don't know why
it always starts with the stupid train
and Democrats are always like we gotta
build a new train anyway
um the so they're uh uh he goes to work
on the train and he's in work within 20
minutes however she has to ride the bus
which takes up to three hours which
means she's going to be on the bus
she'll be late for work blah blah blah
but she has a lower uh social credit
score
and it says she recycles she does all
these things she does the right things
she raises her children right etc etc
Visa journalist which requires her to
talk to unsavory people with different
uh uh with different opinions which
lowers her score so she has to take the
bus for three hours every day
she's a journalist
even a journalist will be will have
points deducted if they talk to somebody
who might have a different opinion to me
sort of okay with journalists being
punished in this dystopian future I
don't know if you're fully getting me on
this one but they will be punished by
talking to people like us I know like us
that's the problem
well well even that that concept does it
strike you as uh strange or or why is it
that for all the warnings about all of
this in great literature and great
science fiction and biblical stories for
all the warnings of going you know
opening the Ark of the Covenant and
figuring out what the ultimate power is
we still go to it we all there's still
something within all of us otherwise you
know you'd be probably living in well
you have some locations in the middle of
nowhere but in essence we'd all dip out
if we were listening to the warnings
well I do have different places I think
you do and you should if you don't
um I'm pretty sure you told me I could
visit you on one of the dip Out
locations or you'd cordon off a little I
think I think there was a corner I think
it was a corner on the edge where the
zombies would be hitting me first if I'm
not mistaken for sure yeah I'll give you
the soon
um anyway uh uh I I think first of all
where you're where you are is where you
will be you'll have about 72 hours to
move
um you start to see a severe banking
crisis they shut down the banks they
shut things down you better be within 72
hours where you want to be or because
you may not move after that
um uh the um
the reason I think we don't take it
seriously is the same reason I mean I
say this
I say this in humility and also with the
knowledge it's been said forever
and I think this is why people don't
take it seriously
I think I could see The Return of Christ
in my lifetime
I think that could happen
will it I don't know I have no idea
scriptures say you should be prepared
for it am I really prepared for that no
why because it's probably not gonna
happen again it's the normalcy bias
it things like this especially in
America do not happen
but it can and it is happening and it's
not normal
would you connect some of this to uh
what people have lately been calling the
crisis of meaning that particularly
younger people are happening that are
happening having in that
they're so confused about things and
they're they're leaders and their elders
and parents generations and all of this
stuff has failed them that in a weird
way when lockdowns came around when
mandates came around they kind of wanted
it because it was just something it was
just something that was different than a
thing or when you think about the antifa
soldiers and the BLM people did they
really want to burn down their cities
and communities probably not if you
really sat them down but it was just
something and and that impulse is a very
strong impulse
never really thought of it that way
that's terrifying Dave I think you're
right
um
I I think there's going to become I mean
you can't put the kinds of people out on
the street and we're talking
30 percent by 2030. unemployment double
that of the Great Depression and it's
never coming back
you can't put those kinds of people out
on the street and expect things to go
well so they better have a good handle
on you uh and a way to keep you as Naval
Harare says um uh medicated and online
um so I think that there's going to be
a couple of things could happen if we're
really fortunate
uh one there could be a Great Awakening
kind of like the Jesus movement of the
70s which took the hippie movement which
was going downhill quickly into drugs
and everything else and turned it into
an uplifting kind of movement uh the
Jesus hippies there's a chance that life
be has become so meaningless in a way
that it did kind of in the 1960s that we
will find meaning again
um
also there is
right now we're fascinated by things we
can do that aren't real you know things
that we can you know the the filters we
use and the and the way we I mean
as somebody who has taken
thousands and thousands of pictures with
people
in the last five years maybe three for
sure
I have noticed younger people when they
take a picture of themselves or take a
picture they have especially girls they
have this pose that they go into it's
almost always the same uh and it always
happens they're not individuals anymore
they're
that's who they are in photos
and it's disturbing but I think we have
a chance of
starving for reality
and if we don't start getting hungry for
reality we're gonna be in trouble
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell